president biden has a big mess on his
hands what else is new when it comes to
china the communist now threatening
nancy pelosi over her possible trip to
taiwan saying it's a red line that she
should not cross and there are fears the
chinese could shoot down pelosi's plane
if she travels there wow doesn't sound
like president biden thinks it's a good
idea
mr president do you think it's a good
idea for speakers
i i think that
the military thinks it's not a good idea
right now
but uh i i don't know what the status of
it is
um the biden white house is reportedly
working behind the scenes to warn the
speaker
that's how we found out of the dangers
of going uh but some republicans think
pelosi can't back down now
speaker pelosi should absolutely go
forward with her trip to taiwan we
cannot back down the face of these
chinese threats if joe biden does if he
prevents nancy pelosi or any other
member of congress from traveling to
taiwan
it will create a major foreign policy
crisis what kind of message that said if
she doesn't go if she allows the bully
to win and biden allows them to win and
let's not allow china to dictate where
any american citizen goes to meet any
others
geraldo china promises a firm response
what do you think that means i mean
they're not gonna shoot down a plane
well i hope i hope you're right remember
the russians did shoot down uh korean
air flight 007 so it is possible the uh
that a civilian airliner could be shot
down and they are at times crazy enough
that would do it
uh yeah but it wasn't considered an act
of war when they uh when they shot down
the korean airliner uh
or if it was it didn't lead to war it's
a very very sensitive topic taiwan is by
united states policy part of china it's
this big island off the coast of china
it's where the uh when the communists
took over china it's where the the
democratic forces uh were in exile but
we negotiated away taiwan's right to
sovereignty to regularize normalized
relations with china
should she go now i think the only way
nancy pelosi should go to china now is
with kevin mccarthy the
republican leader of the house where you
have republican and democrat together to
show at least the chinese that it's not
a parochial partisan act that it's a it
is a bipartisan act that americans are
in it together the taiwanese deserve
their freedom although they are like
hong kong and eventually china will take
them over
kennedy what if she flies with some
orphans and some puppies no one's going
to shoot it down uh the chinese would
greg will it really no i don't know i
don't think they're going to shoot her
down and i think she should go greg i
know you're a huge fan of the crown yeah
i love the series don't you remember
when queen elizabeth went to ghana and
met with nakrumah and brought him back
on side because jackie kennedy got drunk
at a dinner party and badmouth the queen
nancy pelosi can be our queen right now
the first time that's all she wants is
her icy fingers on the scepter and this
will be her moment if she doesn't back
down she will earn a lot of respect from
people and she shouldn't listen to
president lebron james no
there you go i didn't know he was
president dana this is so weird i didn't
know that people could i mean like why
can't you just go
right why can't we go to taiwan well
this is also a very interesting thing
like once again president biden is
kicking off the week having an argument
that's intra party right
it's not as if it was you know senator
tom cotton says i'm going to go to
taiwan which he could if he wanted to of
course but
she was already going to go to japan she
had a planned trip
somebody leaked
that she was going to go to try to get
her not to go i don't know who that was
but we should never be in this position
in the first place she should have been
in japan and then quietly been able to
say and now i'll be going to taiwan and
rather now we have the situation where
they were trying to de-escalate but now
they have escalated it even further and
i understand that and also nancy pelosi
did invite republicans to go with her i
don't know if it was kevin mccarthy but
in particular but there it was going to
be a bipartisan congressional delegation
type of trip which is what you usually
have but we never should have been in
this position in the first place i
believe
that
what president biden is saying is that
they don't want to escalate tensions
but by not going but by saying she
shouldn't go that is only going to lead
to down the road to further escalating
tensions if you don't nip it in the bud
now
you know jessie in the green room you
said i think nancy should go on the
condition she doesn't return i thought
that was rather rude of you i mean can't
you put partisan politics aside no i
think that was her husband paul pelosi
that said that well he she is going to
be taking the car keys that's good yeah
good because he should be taking ubers
from now on china basically killed a
million americans with a virus and now
they're telling us where or we can't go
no i've had it with the chinese i've had
it with them if nancy wants to go visit
an ally let her go and if they touch a
hair on her head
that hair well groomed illegally at a
salon without a mask during a quarantine
but i don't care
we will unleash hell upon the mainland
we already have a carrier strike group
there in the western pacific the u.s
ronald reagan i'm sure nancy loves the
sound of that and we have a destroyer up
and down the taiwan on straight or
whatever it's called we can we can do
whatever we want to the chinese they're
not going to do anything she's probably
going over there because they just
passed the chip spill and they we design
a lot of chips and they manufacture them
in taiwan and then they send them back
so there's probably she's probably just
kind of maybe looking for investment
opportunities for the family or let me
just establishing a very good commercial
connection between the two countries
well that's a good point about it but i
mean about uh kovit and also when you
consider the fentanyl aspect of this
they've killed more than a million
americans i mean newt went over there in
97 they didn't touch newt yeah
don't say anything
i won't but you knew exactly what i was
i knew where your mind was going yeah hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now